hi this is Adam Devine and blake anders
and we're here at comic-con talk about
the fabulous furry freak brothers it's
our new cartoon and we are doing some
thirst tweets as we are i think I'm
legitimately in love with blake like
also can't read there how is it at
legitimate concussed guys like I would
do unmentionable things to lick his
butthole
whoa that it like started really nice
and then I would do unmentionable things
and then immediately mention that Joe
will lick your bubble it seems like one
of the things you wouldn't want to
mention if I could only let one guy bone
me for the rest of my life it would be
Adam fine she's allowing you to promise
yourself yeah is Blake Anderson single
and ready to anal why a dot dot dot I
mean main goal I've got some butt wolfy
yeah why is everyone about your bubble
dude I don't know dude you have a cute
butt though he's got a high but your
butts are really high like on your back
thanks I guess I'm really an Adam
Devine's dick right now thank you
well when was that posted because it
could have faded it was right now oh
right now yeah and then and then like a
month later she's like I'm not into that
any not about I saw it might have been
free game over man she was into my dick
and then game over man came out I reveal
my dick and game over man streaming now
on netflix really good and then if I
turn on the dick it's a decent it's bad
it's there's no pretty fun there's
nothing wrong with it thank you
I can't how do I say that word I can't
read celebrate Vilia celebrate philia is
that abnormal intense design normally
you really I am concussed I fell off a
lime scooter last night no I'm screaming
at you Saburo philia is the abnormally
intense desire to have sex with a
celebrity Blake Anderson good
now was this one or did you guys just
copy and paste my name on to here
because I feel like this wasn't geared
towards me that that could have been
plugged in any celebrity name
sorry Shh I have a wide hole for Adam
Devine cool
hey very cool hey have you imagined the
future imagine their grandkids going
back and looking at their whole tweet
grandpa you said you had a wide hole for
Adam Devon I was joking through face
I love it being described as wide just
rifle wide also does anyone want a wide
hole it doesn't seem that tempting the
only ride I'm interested in riding at
the carnival is Blake Henderson yeah all
right that was fun yeah or the zipper
the zipper is always that's a good one
we said yeah you go at the carnival you
ride the zipper you get some funnel cake
hop on grass likes big Adam Devine has a
very juicy butt and thick thighs and I'm
here for it I'm also here for it well
after a white hole like this seems
really tan yeah that was just this is
like pretty pretty sweet I feel like
your aunt could say that to you on the
way out to your first day at school
I would not want aunt Shelly to mention
my juicy button thoughts why unregulated
to literally anything but I would let
Blake Anderson slam my head into an
easy-bake oven okay can we talk to the
youth of America right now you're too
aggressive yeah all right you don't need
to slam heads and Easy Bake Ovens you
can have normal regular sex and that's
okay to listen to a love song every once
in line okay chill out my butthole is
gaping for no kidding doesn't say that
that's Adam Devine could call me a bunch
and I would still let him tear me open
geez what is going on on my line that's
a real yeah
like I don't understand like tear me
open and and it what called you about
why how about I call you nice names and
then I enter caress and enter I want to
caress and enter not call you and tear
you open but like there's some weird
very sexy quality about Blake Anderson
it is weird I've never been able to
define or verbalize it's just like wow
that's pretty cool yeah you're just like
that's pretty cool and it's from a real
person that I get that a lot I do get
like people are like I'm attracted to
Adam Devine and I don't know why yeah
dude I have no idea why yeah it'll be
like all my friends said I know you
really stupid that I think Blake is hot
but I think he's cute yeah I always get
like I know I'm the only one yeah but I
I get that he's super ugly I didn't like
you mate his face looks like it's made
out of play-doh and he looks like fat
Sean Astin and I'm wide Oh and I'm my
holes are gated for him when will Adam
Devine eat my ass okay hey I'm not you
know I'm not going to I'm glad you're
fans also like my house a lot these kids
are all in do BUTT STUFF wide open I
feel like eating eating butts
we need to eating lettuce things take
over so I'd also like Foods Market in my
butthole
[Music]